chess tour and here they are in another
match up the bar in the middle
what are we seeing from the get-go in
this matchup yeah so it's it's very
tense but Aldrin has made a very
ambitious but committal decision over
the last couple of moves he's Advanced
the F Pawn down the board so he's
initiating a potential Pawn storm
against the white king if he gets Thai
margin here I don't think he'd hesitate
too much he would throw the black G Pawn
down try to dislodge the White Knight
and uh just all the pawns would head
towards that white king I don't like
what Magnus has done with this queen
I've got to say I'm not sure how it
ended up there and uh White's pieces are
a bit locked up for uh for now
um still white is solid of course
shouldn't be too much wrong objectively
but uh yeah he's down on the clock too
practice calcium on C4 have double
isolated pawns yourself I don't think
you do and we actually did just see
Arjun make a move he doesn't push the
pawn he plays Bishop F6 which does
immediately defend this Pawn E5 but
already I'm thinking about exchange
sacrifices we've seen so many a world
champion Champions over the years
including Magnus Carlson eventually try
to plant a rook on D5 I don't think it's
good right here and now but at some
moment look for that kind of exchange
sacrifice yeah getting a strong postpone
in return opening up a nice Outpost for
the White Queen
the problem here maybe is that black
would ignore the Rook at least for a
move or two longer and yeah a very
thematic idea there instead Magnus
captures this Black Knight and Arjun is
hesitating I'm very surprised here I've
got to say if you take with the pawn
long term these are extremely weak and
we see him taking a little bit of of
time here I do not see another way to
defend the E5 Pawn it's also interesting
that white has the possibility to build
up more pressure against the center Pawn
he drops back with the queen and one
idea Rook D5 again super combative with
an exchange sacrifice but this is the
other plan that Magnus has gone for he
wants to really double up the pressure
on the E5 he's looking at setting up
that Queen and Bishop battery along the
diagonal Arjun swipes up The Rook all
the way to E8 so that he can fall back
with the bishop to see it a retreating
move by the bishop just making sure the
pawn on E5 remains defended yep uh it's
just a battle of plans right now and the
more we look at the position the more it
feels like this is a real hole in the in
the black Camp if the white knight could
ever land there that would just be
glorious I'm not sure the path
unfortunately it does take a few moves
but if you imagine the White Knight on
this beautiful juicy Square then uh yeah
you can present this black you don't
even want to tolerate that but uh it
takes too long and a big decision there
by uh origen because he could have
brought his Bishop forward and said he
retreated backwards he's covering that
D5 Square If instead of retreating to F7
he brought his Bishop forward to G4 it
looks like Magnus is turning this
slightly in his favorite at least
momentum wise but will aragaisy fight
back for example we mentioned a possible
Pawn storm at some point I don't think
you can go for it right now to loosening
to weakening but first he takes the time
out to defend uh the seventh rank Magnus
can heat up the pressure it looks like
all of these pieces are pretty much on
their perfect squares right now and uh
can he improve that's the question or
can a regards he just knuckle down
solidify and uh hope to cancel later you
take it first I'm a bishop person I have
to say I love the Bishops but of course
it depends on the position when you've
got a bishop there you're really looking
for an open position so that your
Bishops can be on these diagonals these
are long-range pieces they need space to
breathe and to really Thrive and
flourish but in this position as we can
see the Bishops are behind their own
pawns and there really isn't that much
to play for also Knights are super
tricky let's give me a night I need aha
okay how about you Robert I think I grew
up preferring my Knights over Bishops if
I can just get a neutral position with
the pair of Bishops I already feel like
I have an advantage and so yeah I would
go the Bishops did the Bishops have
range that they can be like archers just
looking afar across the board and Target
everything uh they're defended the pawn
structure is preferable for white and
look at this the 9f3 was putting
pressure on E5 but Magnus pushed his H
Pawn not to create left for his King but
to bring his Knight back just to head
forward to G4 and he induced the
weakness with origin playing hrf simply
to stop that night moving this is Magnus
at his best maneuvering chest and he is
the one with the upper hand here every
move is difficult to walk so he's
burning the clock
on two what is that three minutes on the
clock
transition for black hitting this Pawn
in the center and then flicking a pawn
push up here to open the position at the
right moment just to try and gain some
space Magnus is super flexible and okay
Arjun moves his Rook Magna says okay I'm
clamping down I'm closing the position
even further now there's a nice juicy
Square later for the White Knight I
don't think you want to rush in but uh
definitely no Pawn pushes for black on
that flank Knights thrive in these close
positions Rook over to G1 and push his G
pawn and I think origen understands that
he cannot sit and do nothing because
when that side of the board opens up
it's all fun for white miserable for
black so he plays B5 trying desperately
to claw open the queen side
unfortunately all of White's pieces in
Goods placed there so he does go forward
with your knight G5 idea uh David he
gets that Dark Sword Bishop off the
board E5 becoming even bigger Target C5
now cemented on a dark Square you don't
have a dark Square Bishop to defend it
it would not like this position at all
for black I just don't see any plans
it's just the clock it's just the
position right now in two minutes now
suffering on both and yep super strong
pawns now in the center white still has
ideas of attacking on this side and uh
great positional compensation instead
Magnus he doesn't play the slow approach
of course he goes in with his Queen he's
going to zigzag her into the black camp
and just increase the pressure this is
so unpleasant to have he does swap off a
pair of Pawns we just saw that uh but
now what maybe he's best served as
moving his King side to side and saying
that perhaps Magnus has no way to make
progress yeah argue that black has a
fortress okay first he solidifies
another Pawn but look at that white dark
squared Bishop now if Black's Central
Pawn ever disappears that white dark
Square Bishop rakes across the board and
uh yeah this WOW Magnus just whitening
his eyes
I think shocked by this last decision by
Eric Lassie it did feel to me like
Magnus was trying to provoke this move I
think Magnus would have happily invested
two or three moves to provoke black to
push his Pawn to G6 that's uh Magnus now
it just needs to find a killer blow
Magnus Carlsen is under three minutes on
the clock this is the first game and the
winners semi-final match between these
two the winner of this match goes
through to the winners
final and the loser of this match is
knocked down to the losers bracket to
play the losers quart finals tomorrow
you do have two lives in the double
elimination format wow and a slight
surprise to me at least because we were
just highlighting some potential
checkmating ideas on the dark squares
but Magnus is offered a queen trade
first he dropped back his Bishop to a
one white Bishop in the corner nobody
puts it in the corner it still looks
pretty good there but uh yeah the queen
trade heads towards the end game but the
problem for Arjun is the Rooks are still
on with the Rooks off you could maybe
hold a draw if you're lucky but with the
Rooks on whites Rooks clearly Superior
to those passive uh to their passive
black counterparts what do we think of
this decision
surprised but I think positionally it
seems to work really well he knows he's
got a long-term Advantage with all these
Pawn weaknesses now what black can count
on is that B3 weakness that white has a
lot of weaknesses for black but White's
got one and that's the pawn on V3 he
offers one Trader Brooks the more the
Rooks get off the board the easier the
defensive task gets for Arjun but yes
Magnus will trade off one but not the
other
sorry and we launch up the board with
that work white Rook going after the
isolates uh the black A6 Pawn is the
first Target five seconds as well oh
sorry uh
13 seconds for Argent but uh not much
time at all no and he finally takes the
pawn E5 we've been pointing at it for in
the last bunch of moves he takes it in
the F4 Pawn is next the A6 Pawn is
hanging The Rook just patrolling the
sixth rank here Arjun trying to find any
idea just to stay alive here but with so
little time and I think white can just
start scooping up the material yeah one
Pawn down and it's uh about to increase
magnus's lead first he gives a check oh
discover checks all over the shop here
if Magnus wants first he can just step
his Bishop out the way just uh avoid any
Rook taste Bishop ideas and the threats
continue There we go White's Rook is
going to jump out the way I think we
won't see Arjun fight this one on much
longer you're facing the best end game
player of all time and you're pulling
down with a bunch of weaknesses
yeah it's uh it's that it's just been a
master class for Magnus in terms of
strategy uh strategic play this was
super tough from start to finish for
Archer it was all about giving Magnus
the kind of position where Magnus is the
only one playing and putting that
pressure move after move it's just a
nightmare against him and we see now he
is a couple of Pawns up it's not even
about the the concept of two weaknesses
everything is a weakness in Blacks Camp
right now Arjun with F3 attacks the
Magnus would have to attack the bishop
but also defends the E4 Pawn the bishop
will fall back the G6 Pawn will hang and
now he goes for Rook beard that's an
interesting move but what is the point
you can just pick up the bishop on G4
yeah it's desperation he's hinting at a
counter attack uh if the black Rook can
get active maybe start checking the
white king especially after a trade on
G4 black will have a couple of Pawns
next to each other but it's just uh yeah
it's just a bluff unfortunately I think
with a few seconds left on the clock
Arjun is just playing for tricks and
they don't quite work
has magnets calculated at all I think he
can just figure it out at this point oh
okay yes he has he gives his Bishop back
just to create a pass Pawn over here the
G6 Pawn is still hanging he'll have two
Advanced past pawns that cannot be
stopped and the material count is still
in magnus's favor after all of that so
uh Arjun he's just playing on just to
get these final moves in but that H Pawn
cannot be stopped anymore yep that's uh
white porn will cost black as Rook if
you want to stop it uh actually you
might not even get given the opportunity
a rook trade and white will make a new
Queen Arjun is about to resign losing on
time as well and he logs off immediately
wow it's a win four Magnus crawls in the
in the first game in the winner is
semi-finals he's playing a match against
Arjun Eric icy